not unusual to be loved but it was yeah
hey guys i'm abby shark welcome to
Abby's kitchen and I'm here with my
friend Nikki from health nut nutrition
hey guys
so the holidays are officially here it's
it's it's happening folks and I know a
lot of us have tons of family traditions
when it comes to food at the holidays
and a lot of them are super heavy super
rich leave you with a total carb coma
and it's delicious but I think we can
lighten some of those family favorites
up and that's what we're gonna be doing
today
so we've got two awesome recipes to
share with you Nikki what are you making
I'm making my grandmother's rice pudding
recipe straight from Portugal which I
help I'd just a little bit so good and
I'm gonna be doing a stuffing and we
know stuffing is traditionally like
basically just carbs and fat but mine is
lower in fat higher in protein and has
lots of veggies snuck in there
okay so Nikki we're gonna start off this
holiday healthy stuffing with some
turkey sausage so basically if you want
to skip the turkey you can you can do
that if you wanted it just put it in
your stuffing why not two in one and
that's how I like to roll so I'm just
gonna put on a little bit key if you
want to put some oil in the pan I've got
some sausage here and you can honestly
use whatever kind of turkey sausage you
want play with it whatever you can find
out that the grocery store totally works
alright so we're just browning off this
sausage here and I know I don't have a
use Nikki but I'm obsessed with stuffing
it's basically the reason for the
holiday meal in my books and I know you
know when I was growing up my mom
accidentally put too much water in the
pot when she went to put the stuffing
mix in and it totally resulted in a
waterlogged soggy stuffing and I rushed
to the kitchen I was like mom I can fix
it I have a Christmas mirror
here and that Christmas miracle was a
loaf of bread that was pretty much stick
getting sale in the kitchen I ripped it
up threw it in and bam I have saved a
miracle happen a miracle or Christmas
miracle right there
okay so we're just gonna return the pan
to the heat Nicki if you want to grab
those Brussels sprouts I've been loving
Brussels sprouts recent my favorite
Durham in yeah let's brown those bad
boys so here's a funny thing I don't
know how to spell Brussels sprouts
because for some reason it right it's
always like oh you got even errors like
yeah yes what is the truth
can somebody got sakes if Google doesn't
know maybe they're you know maybe Siri
knows it should ask theory we should ask
Siri hey Siri how do you spell Brussels
sprouts oh yes oh yeah well I'm gonna
change my blog post because I made a
Brussels sprout salad alright so next
let's grab the celery and the mushrooms
garlic and the sage just gonna Brown up
everything else and instantly you smell
the holidays and now we get to assemble
so if you want to grab the bread you can
take some of the chicken stock and we've
got some eggs that I've beaten here
just soak that puppy
versus when going for a swim in the
bread the soggy bread and the eggs as
well
perfect so I've got our mushrooms going
down you want to throw the pear in there
we've got our Brussels sprouts and our
sausage oh yeah some cranberries some
pecans and now tell me why you decided
this bowl would be the best choice for
this recipe I made a lot of questionable
choices Nikki that's lying you'll have
to just accept about me IIIi thought it
was I thought it was gonna work it's a
little excessive big stuffing this time
it's gonna either they all have ever
said or just me maybe just me she's got
our casserole dish just give it a little
flatten down that's nothing that's
nothing awesome all right so this
basically just goes into the oven at 350
degrees for about 45 minutes or so just
until it's nice and browned on top and
it's still a kind of moist on the bottom
but that's kind of how I like it
so to the oven
and check that and all that's not Amazo
good it's not so much flavor
I love the Brussels press mama sharp
wouldn't shout she knows she knows she
knows that's coming this she does she
does okay guys thanks so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this healthy
take on holiday stuffing also you're
gonna want to check out Nikki's channel
over here she has an amazing rice
pudding that you definitely don't want
to put on the holiday table this year so
good so good so creamy you guys are
gonna love it yes and if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some of
your favorite family holiday recipes
that you want to put a little healthy
spin on we'll do our little take on them
and of course subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen
bye happy holidays so basically it's got
a nice thin casing oh yeah it's kind of
a balloon it well what are you making me
do you wanna ass or I'm gonna reindeer
reindeer that one's gonna be challenging
you